guys I'm so happy it's so lovely to talk
with you to again as we're heading into
the holiday season approaching the new
year are there any specific activities
that each of you enjoy with your family
during the festive
season oh my well car caroling I was
gonna say yeah food for vality um yeah
the holidays are just you know for us
it's all about family um Drew is
actually coming over Drew and Linda are
coming over here um next week to we're
having a little caroling get together so
we're gonna sing Christmas carols and
have some some good food and some good
drinks love that it's uh it's been it's
been from since we were kids uh may have
told you this before but uh Jonathan and
me our parents and our our older brother
jie we would always every year get
together at the holidays we would go
door to door to our neighbors and
Friends caroling to them and by the end
we have like 40 people my dad and me
playing the guitar sometimes Jonathan
would play the bag pipes right mostly
time I would dress up as Santa the uh
yeah but the one thing we I do miss that
you know CU in Canada where we were at
the holiday time there was always snow
and so it was nice to have the snow and
the playing and so I I actually got the
snow machine and I'm putting in like a
little snow area on the property here so
our kids and and Drew is going to bring
Parker over so they can experience what
snow is because in La you don't get any
yeah no that's so sweet I know tobing is
like a good Canadian memory to have all
the time I I love that memory of mine um
I'd love to talk to you guys a little
bit about the White House Christmas
special I just watched it it is a fun
it's so fun um and it's now available to
watch on Max there is such a beautiful
Whimsy and Magic to the decor this year
so what was something that stuck out to
both of you on the design Spectrum well
I think the one thing for me that I love
is that you know it's brought throughout
the entire design is TW the Night Before
Christmas this is the 200 year
anniversary of the publication and
that's pretty cool to me I have some
some old vintage books and CH like
children's books um I didn't have that
so when I went in and we're looking at
the old books and then we see how they
carry that throughout with the the
reindeer um as as soon as you walk
through uh the doorway everything about
it was magical and I really love Dr
Biden's Vision the whole thing she
wanted to brought to life was this sort
of childhood Whimsy and it really did it
did happen and some people may think how
on Earth are you going to do these
things like have a giant Christmas tree
that's growing through the East Portico
roof or having the reindeer flying and
as soon as those ideas were conveyed
then all of a sudden our mind started
working the incred there were 300
volunteers incredible companies as well
like glitterville that were working on
it and uh pulled it off and it it was
magical you walk through there and you
feel like you're a kid again that was
actually the greatest part of it is that
one big tree growing through the East
Portico the idea was all the presents
all the tree it was all oversized so
that you feel as an adult like you're a
kid again looking up the tree it was
amazing yeah no I loved that I thought
it was a really cool touch um I'm sure
you guys also I don't want to spoil for
all the viewers but you do sing to Dr
Jill Biden I thought that was such an
amazing moment so were you guys Star
yeah it was really it was really
cool Dr Biden is an educator and so
she's all about um books she teaches uh
literature and so for me there's it's
almost like when you're in her presence
she is fully in on whatever you're
saying whatever you're talking about and
she's she's really uh engaging in that
way and I love that when you're having a
conversation with somebody and I love
that the idea of educating uh children
through story was the entire idea of
this design it was pretty cool you know
I I decorated the White House last year
with Zoe and uh so this is my second
year and Dr Biden is just so down to
earth and so kind and and wanted to make
sure that everyone felt represented
because this is the people's house and
so uh it was really nice to be back
again and and to see it all come to life
and and showcase that but it really is
it's I mean it's a magical place it's
the most famous house in the
country and uh now we get to say we
decorated it so you know it's cool too I
mean walking around we see some there's
a lot of crafting in fact you know next
year we're probably going to bring our
mom with us because she loves this and
Zoe and Linda love crafting U but we're
seeing all the things that creating
paper rings or popcorn strings there are
a lot of things that they were doing the
volunteers were doing with us that were
literally what we did as children so
that was fun it was almost like my young
nostalgic Drew coming back a little bit
of that action well and that's what I
think I think people are going to be
able to watch the show and I know it's
streaming now on Max as well and people
can watch it and take inspiration home
there are so many projects that people
will learn from watching it that they
can do immediately yeah for sure and
let's talk about celebrity IOU um I love
this show and I appreciate the intimate
look at just how you know these
celebrities they're they're more than
just celebrities they have actually
these people behind them who have been
rallying they've been helping them
throughout their years um you know this
season shaping up to be another
incredible one so can you tease any
particularly emotional moments or
surprising challenges that were possibly
encountered while working with the
celebrities this year it's hard to pick
just one because there's so much
connection the way every single
celebrity talks about um the people who
are part of their life so Sterling K
Brown uh giving back to you know their
Nanny and assistant this is somebody who
has been a massive part of their life
they are everybody is almost like family
that they're giving back to and to see
that she was struggling um you know she
has her four kids plus her grandchild um
but she was told uh by the uh the city
by the courts that she's not allowed to
adopt her grandchild until she has a
house that will fit the family um for
them all to live in she was searching
and searching with how expensive La is
she just couldn't afford so she finally
found a home but she spent every pany on
getting the place and she wasn't able to
actually renovate it so Sterling brought
us in to actually transform the kitchen
and the eating area and everything so
the family can actually use it and now
she's able to adopt her granddaughter
like it's that CR critical a moment of
what we're doing to help these families
transform their lives it's pretty heart
heartwarming yeah it was the same too
with um Regina Hall's episode it she was
giving back to Vonda who whose daughter
has CLE camia and suffers from really
bad respiratory issues and and illness
um and it turns out that their house not
only did not have air conditioning but
the heating system in there it was so
old and absolutely unhealthy it was
pumping around really really dirty air
throughout the house and so this wasn't
even just about having a house that's
that's beautiful it's about having a
house that's safe and so that that
episode got really really emotional and
especially for the reveal because you're
transforming these recipients lives this
is a huge thing and then on the flip
side it's also so fun because you see
you know Rosario Dawson and Zoe selan in
their sledgehammering walls out and and
actually both of them sledgehammering
Drew taking Drew down this is a new
running gag by the way I love this
because we have it started with Hal
Berry who who choked out Drew tackled
him to the ground then Zoe s and Rosario
all these Powerhouse women are now
taking Drew out maybe it's so that the
show becomes surprising when you when
you think about it Zoe's you know like a
superhero Rosario's a Jedi H was a
superhero I mean I don't know it's I I
need to shape up I need to become like a
a DC Superhero I'll be Aquaman's like
awkward cousin or
you can be you'll be or the evil brother
that works yeah yeah um you know I know
you two work with the Stars together on
these projects but there are some
established design elements in these
Renovations that I feel like are they
implicit signature additions from each
of you like perhaps a feature while a
super Jonathan or a type of Marvel
countertop is very true do you add any
of yourself into these projects no I
think the one thing I mean joh you can
ask for yourself but the one thing for
us is as designers we never try to
impose us on whoever we're working with
because we're not the ones who live
there and I think that that's a mistake
for a lot of designers to to try and
force things on the client so for us
that's why the celebrity is so uh such
an integral part of the design because
we don't know these people like they do
and so when we really hear like when Ry
was telling us the story um of how his
assistant has been life-changing for him
yeah he he jokes like he he's he says
I'm a little neurotic and I I'm a stress
ball and she's the one who knows how to
diffuse that and work with it well for
for him to tell us over the years and
years of and years of going to her house
and letting us know what needs to change
we wouldn't know that on our own
especially when we're trying to surprise
some of these people they don't know
what we're doing we can't just go and
ask them what they want so we I was
literally talking with this with Zoe
about this yesterday because uh that you
know I've seen designers who refuse to
put a microwave in any kitchen that they
design like well that's not realistic
most families use a microwave or who
refuse to put upper cabins you need to
design homes that make life easier which
means you need to really understand and
appreciate the recipient I had a
slightly different answer than what Drew
said I said that if you ever look at
these designs and you see a really crazy
expensive fancy feature that's usually
something drew added so you know why not
one nice thing though is I will say with
our shows is we use ourselves we kind of
pimp ourselves out to get as much free
stuff for these homeowners as we
possibly can so we have incredible
Partners you know when you see the Brad
Pit episode with that Murphy bed that
comes down over the sofa that just
looked like shelves before all of those
things you know these companies work
with us to to offer this technology and
uh we couldn't do what we do if it
wasn't for that team yeah you know we
even if you look like my biic episode it
was a backyard renovation but I I love
when you see these celebrities do what
what M was doing where she was literally
in this heavyduty equipment she was
driving it to knock things out pull out
old stumps clear the space there's
nothing they won't do because they love
these people so much and for her n
is like her sister from another mister
and she met her way back when when one
of her babies were being born um and
actually I think it was at Disneyland
they they're standing in line or at some
event they're saying they just randomly
met in the line but anyway to the the
length of time some of these um people
the slers have known for a decade two
decades or more and we we really rely on
their that story and how they know each
other so well to know what we have to do
even all those expensive things I want
to add it's all from what we could
literally talk for like an hour about
funny behind the scen I know we only
have minutes here but uh there are so
many stories that's what I think makes
the show the number one show you know it
makes it's so fun for people to watch
it's because you see this Human Side of
these celebrities and we get to ask them
stuff that nobody's ever asked them on a
red carpet yeah and I do want to just
note that I love that stained glass Crow
it was so beautiful and it made me cry
my sister was watching it with me we're
just like how did you guys come up with
that it was such a accent it was such a
nice thing and it's like the light I
feel like it's a beautiful met yeah yeah
chisty said it was important it would
just remind them of family and yeah
absolutely I loved it and I got to do it
like to be a part of doing it Hands-On
was pretty cool Lyon and I did a date
night there there as well after because
we I love the idea of creating like a
little stained glass yeah you know in
terms of the season um something that I
really loved uh in the anal Ferris
episode uh Jonathan you know when she
asked you what's it like being a twin
you said it's like having a built-in
best friend and that really touched me
so much cuz I am so close to my sister
she's 5 years older but everyone always
thinks we look like twins and I always
feel like it's one of those things where
I say I was born with the best friend
like I automatically have so um how is
your dynamic as brothers and formed a
relationship as design partners that
have perhaps expanded your craft in ways
you couldn't without the other well I
think the nice thing is no one knows you
better than your sibling especially if
you shared a womb together um hence our
shirt that says Bros womb to tomb when
you sit on someone's head in the womb
for a while you really get to know them
yeah the one thing I would say we say
when you have a friend and you finish
each other's sentences it's like that
times a 100 sometimes Drew and I will
have entire conversations where we're
not actually saying any like if you were
listening as a third party you wouldn't
understand what's happening but we call
it our twin tuition we know exactly what
we're getting and what we want and uh it
just works out yeah yeah I would say the
one thing with respect to that that is
great though is because like in any
relationship you spend time with
somebody you know what their strengths
and weaknesses are and you know as a
designer not that johnan has weaknesses
but you know for me I love to dive into
spatial planning like to figure out the
tetris the puzzle of it and Jonathan um
you know pulling rooms together in a
different way there are ways that we can
have in flow and work off each other
we're not always doubling up on
everything yeah for sure um before I let
you guys go I always love chatting with
you um the shows are so amazing I always
feel like the prer brother show I
learned so much I I try to make my own
background look like something that you
guys have done um looks amazing thank
you um so I like the little pop of
Presley yes of course Gotta Have yeah
kind of there he's he's very popular um
you know what role do you see celebrity
IOU playing and inspiring viewers to
consider Home Improvement projects of
their own you know the big thing I would
say is aside from Home Improvement
projects of their own we do try to show
how everybody can get hands- on and be a
part of something but also know when to
work with professionals but truly the
biggest part of that show is trying to
inspire people to do a little something
nice for someone you love it doesn't
have to be renovating their house but
there are small things that you could do
that could be really meaningful and and
life-changing for people and I think
it's great to use a platform like ours
to Showcase technologies that are
actually good for human health for the
environment that uh are the future of of
home technology so um you know no one
has a bigger platform than we do and
we're fortunate that we uh we're pretty
strict about what we showcase but I'm
glad we've had a positive influence on
everybody for sure and I'm just so happy
that everyone gets to watch Liberty IOU
premieres January 1st on HTV and Max and
on that note guys Merry Christmas and
Happy New Year to you both so excited to
thank you to you as well thank you all
the best see you in the new
year